بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
والصلاه والسلام على رسوله الكريم وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
ف قراءتنا موصوله لكتاب رياض الصالحين من
كلام سيد المرسلين
للحافظ الفقيه
المحدث ابي زكريا النووي رحمه الله تعالى
وقد وصلنا فيه الى الباب الاول الحديث
الخامس
باب الاخلاص واحضار النيه
يقول وعن ابي يزيد
معن بن يزيد بن الاخنس
رضي الله عنهم
وهو وابوه وجده صحابيون
قال كان ابي يزيد اخرج دنانير يتصدق بها
فوضعها عند رجل في المسجد فجئت فاخذتها
فاتيته بها
فقال والله ما اياك ارد
فخاصمته الى رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
فقال
لك ما نويت يا يزيد ولك ما اخذت يا معن
رواه البخاري
في هذه الروايه
يقول الحافظ وعن ابي يزيد يزيد هذه كنيه
الراوي معا هو راوي الحديث وابوه يزيد بن
الاخنس صحابي معن الراوي صحابي
ويزيد ابن الاخنس صحابي والاخنس صحابي
لذلك قال بالجمع رضي الله عنهم رضي الله
عنهم لان الجمع في لغه العرب في المشهور
ثلاثه فما زاد
فهؤلاء
صحابه كلهم
وهذا شرف عظيم ويدل على شمول دعوه النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول النووي وهو يعني
معا وابوه يزيد وجده
الاخنس صحابيون
يحدث معا فيقول كان ابي يزيد
اخرج دنانير يتصدق بها فوضعها عند رجل في
المسجد الدينار من الذهب والدرهم من الفضه
وكما هو عاده الناس ياتي صاحب خير يريد
يريد ان يتصدق فهو لا يدري من احق بصدقته
فياتي الى اصحاب المسجد فيضع الصدقه
عند احد من اصحاب المسجد ويقول من جاء
يطلب شيئا من الصدقه فتصدقوا
بهذا فاعطوه
فاعطاه الدنانير وانصرف
فجاء بعد حين
ابنه يزيد والرجل الذي قد وكل بهذا قد
وكله
فجاء ابنه معا
والرجل في المسجد الذي وكله
يزيد
لم يدري ان هذا ولد المتصدق ما عرف
فجاء وراه محتاجا فاعطاه
فقال
قال فجئت
فاخذتها
بحق لانه
اي يحتاج الصدقه
فلما روح على البيت
الحمد لله فتح الله علينا جئت بهذه
الدنانير فراها
ابوه يزيد فقال هذه دنانير انا تصدقت بها
والله ما اياك اردت
فخاصمته
الى رسول الله
يقول معامته
الى رسول الله بقله ادب لا ليس بقله ادب
ولكن الحق احق ان يتبع والصحابه ما كانوا
يكابرون الحق
ف
جاء هو وابوه الى رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم وقصى عليه ما حدث بينهما فحكم بينهما
رسول الله بقوله
لك ما اخذت يا معا لانك
من اهل الصدقه ولك ما نويت يا يزيد
ظاهر الحديث
من ظاهر كلام النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ان
الصدقه لا تجوز على العيال وهذا لم يفهمه
الفقهاء من هذه الروايه وسياتي التفصيل في
ذلك ان شاء الله
ابي يزيد معن ابن يزيد ابن الاخنس رضي
الله عنه
حديث
صلى الله عليه وسلم
في تعريف المحدثين
وهو الذي عليه اكثر العلماء قديما وحديثا
هو من اجتمع بالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
مؤمنا به ومات على ذلك
ولو لو تخلل هذا الايمان
شيء من الرده على الراجح من اقوال العلماء
صلى الله عليه وسلم
صلى اللهيه عليه وسلم
this is
this isehensive
thresold
the companions are not all the are those
who life are those who fit
‏min compion all these are comp now what
happen is
the father came to thej and someins that
want to be distributed on his behalf in
charity and so he left them there with
someone that was in the
and he left
unbenounc to him his son came in later
and he needed
‏and was grown his son was not a child
at this time he was gr man and so the
man in the know that this was the of the
man who left the coins so he gave them
to him
later on come to find out that
when he saw those coins with his son he
‏I did not in those
you
here
is the stranger a person I have no
connections with no personal investment
in will make myity more
that could be the case but is that a no
is not a as we
صلى الله عليه وسلم
صلى الله عليه
‏is by yourity
and for you speaking to the is what you
have taken meaning of charity because
you have a right to charity someone in
need you fit the criteria of someone who
needs charity this narration is actually
evidence
[Silence]
‏you
‏What is the condition
that a person does not use this charity
to
as we say hit two birds with one
stone. What does that mean? So a person
let say has children, has a wife, has
people that he is responsible for but he
also has a responsibility to give.
‏bir stone giveat to my
even have them birdsone
invalidatesityates
and this is to be
however if a person is not responsible
for this person any longer legislatively
even if it is his
فالفقهاء يشترطون في اعطاء حتى الزكاه
والزكاه شرطها اشد من شرط مجرد الصدقه
فالفقهاء رحمهم الله
يشترطون في ايتاء الزكاه لذي القربى
الا يسقط بذلك حقا واجبا
الا يسقط بذلك حقا شرعيا
كمن تجب عليه النفقه
فهذا لا يجوز له ان يسقط نفقته الواجبه
باعطاء الزكاه بل هذا يجب وهذا يجب
لكن الزكاه والصدقه وما شابه ذلك فاهل
القرابه قرابه الرجل هم اولى الناس بذلك
هم اولى الناس بذلك
كما سياتي ان شاء الله تعالى عن النبي
وشاهد الحديث لك ما نويت يا يزيد
يعني الشيخ رحمه الله المؤلف وضع هذه
الروايه لهذه
الفقره من الحديث لك ما نويت
ولك لك ما اخذت
فهذا
لم يؤثر في هذا
على اي حساب على حساب النيه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
يزيد
ان شاء والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على
نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
والحمد لله رب العالمين وجزاكم الله خيرا